hey guys merry here and i'm here with
will game designer from Thunder Lotus
thanks for joining me thanks for having
me and you're gonna show me a game that
I actually kind of fell in love with
back at PAX East but now the game is out
and ready to be seen by anyone this is
jotun yeah jones a hand-drawn action
exploration game set in Norse mythology
were out on steam for Windows Mac and
Linux no awesome so before when i played
it i saw this like crazy snow level with
this massive boss it looks like that
might be to the right over here wow that
guy looks familiar to me but you're
going to show me something that I at
least haven't seen yet yeah so we're
going to go over the storm region
there's a level called the night sky and
a level called birther birther full
nears roost okay what am i a mouthful
yeah the bosses haggle eyes the storms
open okay let's go ahead and check this
out something that anyone who hasn't
seen this game yet you didn't check out
that video at PAX East what drew me to
this game was the unique style visually
this is all done with hand-drawn
animation yeah it's everything's hand
drawn in the game all the animation all
the backgrounds everything you see is
hand-drawn so you can see thora here
like she just like her facial
expressions everything it gives us a lot
of character mm-hmm to the different
characters yeah it's always good to see
something done so uniquely and you can
really see the detail when the camera is
zoomed in like it is here I remember
when I played it before the camera had
to be so zoomed out because there was
this massive boss that I was trying to
defeat but when it zoomed in you really
get to see all the detail and all the in
all the environments that you've created
plus so we honest with you snow
environments actually may be hard to put
in a lot of detail cuz everything's
white right but yeah absolutely in this
one Oh me look at that sweet bird like
everything there's probably a lot more
that your artists were able to put
detail into yeah absolutely that was a
ver third full near the the Hawke who
stands on the unnamed eagle's head
there's a lot of crazy stories in Norse
mythology that being one of them
right and so you're actually taking
pieces from mythology and putting it
into the game as much as possible we
tried to copy paste things in apology
we're just a bunch of the scammers
basically stealing ripping off the
entire edo's and everything everything
we could put in we put in of course we
sometimes took creative liberties but
the way it goes well at least you're
honest about it those are good and like
those are good stories too so it's nice
to to get some of that Lulu's got just
got wrecked yeah it took a lot of your
health I think was something a lot of
other people might also not know about
this game is the difficulty levels is
actually quite high I remember when I
played it before it was not easy to take
down these bosses they are massive and
their attacks do tremendous amount of
damage obviously it's still playable and
a very fun enjoyable game but the
difficulty level is there absolutely one
of our inspirations is no Dark Souls
obviously shadow crosses that sense of
scale but a lot of people say oh yeah
it's kind of like Dark Souls and in that
and I definitely agree it's about for
the boss fights it's about the reading
the bosses patterns and dodging at the
last minute and stuff like that so we're
trying to make it hard but not unfair in
any way
so this is a level where we have
constellations in the background the
Norse constellations and you have to
activate beacons to replicate them once
you you have them a hora borealis bridge
shows that allows you to get to the next
place that's really cool about the
Turkish so we have here we have like a
gate so you have four different
constellations you have to activate and
get to in this level Freya the speed
boost is pretty useful because it lets
you get around quite a bit faster mmm
because you're traversing a lot more in
this one exactly and as you saw as you
heard we have a fully Icelandic voice
overs in the game so everything is
trying to stay as true as possible to
Old Norse it's actually the language
it's the closest to to Old Norse how
long does the speed boost last four it's
not super long it's about eight seconds
I think that's very shy he used to be
longer but it was super broken make me
some quite too powerful because it
boosts your attacks as well and you can
actually stack the God powers in between
them so you could like you can stack
Thor who has a ready attack boost with
Freya
the valley must minister history
I'll actually playing her last night
just to do some testing and I didn't
have enjoyed had a joy a gamepad hope
the beater such a noob hopefully I do
better I think a lot of games are meant
to be played with the gamepad basically
yeah jodan works with yeah it makes it
quite a bit more difficult if you don't
terrifying so now that we're in combat
you should go over just the basic moves
that you do have to work with right so
you have the dodge which does slow you
down at the end so that dodging isn't
faster than money and then you have your
light attack you have a combo attacks so
if you get the timing right on the
normal attack you also have a dodge
attack so you end your dodge with ya and
then we have a heavy attack which takes
quite a bit of time to charge up but it
does a lot more dps
so you can see these pillars here in
this fight they're actually kind of a
bit of a puzzle mechanic going on when
you light up all four that's what causes
her to to overcharge okay and then you
can get in a hit and here's a good place
to show off the God powers usually
hitting the boss on the head is a good
idea okay if you charge up with Mjolnir
there it's a good time to get some extra
bandages it's cool that impacts the
environment of the level as well your
attack right yeah absolutely we tried to
mix things up a little bit and in the
winter Joan the whole battleground turns
to ice mid-fight and in this one it's
that but here at mid-fight she splits
into two and she's got a lot of help to
you see it in the bottom right there's a
lot to take down here yeah we try not to
be like like you know like bullet
sponges type of types of bosses but at
the same time they are Norse giants so
they do have quite a bit of help
mr. Povey people don't know this game is
currently out where can people will pick
it up wicked on steam for Windows Mac
Linux okay and how much is it it's
fifteen dollars USD alright awesome well
that was jodan I hope you guys enjoy it
as much as i did a pretty unique game
missed both in gameplay style and visual
style I think these types of games are
so cool and they're harder and harder to
find so if you guys like it you can pick
it up today it's out thanks a lot thanks
so much
you